in researching director Ed's wig he
talked about how an actor should go
through the psychological realities of a
character is that something that you do
and if so what kind of process is that
mm-hmm great question yeah you know to
find your way into somebody else's mind
is is a process and the more you learn
about how they lived who they were how
they express themselves in a number of
different situations can in trying to
put yourself into their shoes can often
lead you to what they were thinking
under those circumstances and that I
find to be captivating if you can
actually get into it you know it's a
fragile business I find it often it's
like splitting atoms in some ways
because we all have our own things going
on in our heads and to try to submerge
yourself into something else is a is a
wonderful challenge not often is one
successful and actually producing a
complete performance or a complete
character but it's it's really fun to
try what did playing Paul and also
watching bobby fischer's life teach you
about your own life there's some smart
people out there you know and these were
two of them Paul was a rigorous
individual and a tremendous spirit and a
ferocious with a ferocious intellect in
enough him himself and it was a pioneer
in the in the field of intellectual
property in regards to musicians at that
time and
[Music]
to to jump in their skin and to sort of
see you know what they did or how they
think and to try to put yourself in
their position makes you think about I
guess your own life and what it is that
you're doing or trying to do and the
ability to bring along with whatever it
is you're trying to do it's a big world
and there's a lot of smart people out
there what made you say yes to this role
getting to work with that and Toby and
Peter and Liev and Robin and Lily and
everybody who is a part of the great
cast
the story is interesting to me and I
wanted to know more about Bobby Fischer
too because I didn't know anything about
him you know now I do and it's a it's a
boy what a rollercoaster of a life he
lived sad but also passionate and
interesting Thanks